[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the UK economy shrinks unexpectedly in
March but the first quarter still sees
slight growth
British software Tycoon Mike Lynch is
extradited to the United States after
losing a long-running legal battle
Elon Musk says he's appointed a new
chief executive to run Twitter but he
doesn't divulge the name
plus the plot is ticking to the
Eurovision song contest final I'll be
speaking to its main sponsor tiktok
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City the UK economy
unexpectedly contracted during March but
still managed to grow during the first
quarter of the year the office for
National statistics said that the
economy contracted by three tenths of
one percent during March it said that
contraction was due mainly to weakness
in the services sector the biggest part
of the UK economy and in particular in
the motor trade the ons pointed out that
new car registrations during March
normally a key month for the trade
remained below pre-pandemic levels well
the March contraction followed the
economy flatlining during February and
growing by half of one percent in
January it meant that during the first
quarter as a whole the economy grew by
one-tenth of one percent the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt has just been reacting to
the news
one would possibly have predicted even
three months ago and that's partly
because of what the governor of the bank
of England said yesterday measures in
the budget that are helping to help
companies to recruit tackle some of the
underlying problems in the economy but
there is still much work to do we still
have inflation that is much too high
that's causing a lot of pressure for
families up and down the country that's
why we've got to stick to our plan to
get inflation down to get growth up and
to get the economy Motoring in the way
that we all want
um the UK Remains the only G7 country in
which the quarterly measure of GDP has
not recovered to its pre-covered level
in March the economy went backwards when
will we get back to where we were three
years ago
if you look at the most up-to-date
monthly figures we are now above
pandemic levels across the whole economy
but only marginally and we want to see
much faster growth that's why we need to
stick to our plan above all to bring
inflation down because that's a drag on
growth but also part of that plan is to
relieve the pressure on families as we
go through this difficult period that's
why we've increased this month the
national living wage to its highest ever
level we're doing big payments to help
people with their electricity bills but
the long-term solution is not subsidy
it's actually getting inflation down and
growth up and on the quarterly basis
when will we get back to where we were
I think it's for the economist to say
um when we are going to get our costly
levels back to pre-pandemic levels but
Germany is also in the same situation as
we are the bigger picture here is that
growth is picking up much faster than
anyone thought possible that's
encouraging the international monetary
fund here in Japan with me say that the
British economy is on the right track
but there's much to do we've still got
to get inflation down and we've got to
stick to our plan to make sure we remove
those pressures on people's weekly
shopping bills strike action is holding
that growth it's also leading to
canceled operations and school closures
when will you resolve these disputes
we want to resolve the public sector
strikes as quickly as we can we're
prepared to be completely reasonable we
will talk about anything except measures
that will entrench high inflation
because the root cause of the anger of
the people who are striking at the
moment is that the cost of their weekly
shop has gone up by more than their
salary and we don't want to be here in a
year's time having the same discussion
so it is challenging for everyone as we
see when interest rates go up but it's
the right thing to do because if we
bring down inflation we can restore the
value of people's pay packets and stop
people having to worry about prices
going up Chancellor thank you
joining me now as our business
correspondent gurpreet no one got a
pretty bit of a surprise this number it
looks like a consumer facing Services
was the main drag on growth yes that's
right Ian these figures were worse than
expected and we weren't exactly going
into this with particularly high
expectations in March the economy
contracted by 0.3 economists were
expecting it to Flatline but in the
first three months of the year the first
quarter it did manage to eke out some
growth of 0.1 and we're really being hit
on multiple fronts widespread strike
action is dampening growth in the public
sector but also a toxic mix of high
inflation and high taxes are weighing
heavily on disposable incomes which
means people are a bit more cautious
about going out to spend the office for
National statistics said today that the
consumer facing Services sector that
includes everything from shops and
restaurants to hairdressers and travel
agencies shrank by 0.8 in March and in
the first three months of the year can
consumer spending was flat it's largely
still being supported by people running
down their lockdown savings so there's
not a huge amount
to celebrate here but Jeremy Hunt as you
heard was trying to put a positive spin
on it saying at least the economy is
growing and when you consider where we
were at the beginning of the year when
the Outlook looked pretty bleak many
economists were saying that we'd already
be in recession you can see the
positives in it we haven't had that much
talked about recession and the bank of
England said yesterday that we might
avoid one altogether actually managing
to eke out some growth the problem is
that although we've managed to avoid a
recession we're starting from a pretty
low base and we're the only economy in
the G7 that still hasn't recovered to
its pre-pandemic size so hardly a
massive cause for celebration
okay thanks corporate
well joining me for more now on this is
Paul Dales Who's chief UK Economist at
Capital economics Paul good to see you
this morning I mean this number did take
a few people by surprise what had you
been looking for
um we thought the economy would be flat
in March rather than Contracting
um but I don't think we should overreact
to this because
um on my analysis I think a lot of the
weakness in March itself was due to the
strikes which to some extent are a
temporary drag on the economy hopefully
and also actually unusually wet weather
it was the wettest March for 40 years
and that meant a lot of people actually
just stayed at home rather than go out
and spending so I'd be surprised if
actually GDP didn't rebound a bit in
April is there any possibility of this
being a rogue number we obviously uh
often get revisions to these uh first
cuts from the ons
oh that's always possible I mean
economic statistics are hard to compile
and they get um changed as new
information comes along all the time
um but for me the really big points here
is that we know that the UK economy has
been hit by two dual drags the effect of
high inflation and now the effect of
higher interest rates I think what's
happened is the UK actually should be
quite commented because it's avoided a
recession so far but for me the real
concern is that all the drag from higher
interest rates has yet to come through
households and businesses haven't seen
the full effect on their borrowing costs
so I'm a bit concerned that it's too
early to sound the all clear on the
recession call I think there's still a
risk that the UK might fall into
recession at some point later this year
that's a very good point you make I mean
it was instructive yesterday for me that
Andrew Bailey said that households had
only felt really about a third of the
interest rate Rises that we've had to
date it kind of begs the question why in
that case they they went again yesterday
yes
I think it's a case really that they
they know they've done a lot of work
um to call uh inflation and they know
that will have some effect the problem
is they just don't quite know how much
they need to do and what the effect is
going to be so for me it feels like
um they decided
um to raise interest rates once again to
four and a half percent
um just because there is a risk that
inflation might be a bit stickier than
it expects and I think that's such a
reasonable sensible decision
um I do feel though as we are coming
quite close to the peak in interest
rates I'm not sure whether it will be
4.5 or 4.75 but I don't think we'll go
much further because at some point the
bank will probably say okay we've done
quite a lot we think the effects of
higher interest rates will start to have
a bigger impact on the economy and we
just need to wait and see uh for that
effect to come through absolutely Paul
you mentioned the strikes just now I
mean it's quite interesting in the ons
release it it said that strike action
had clearly had an impact on GDP but it
find it hard to quantify
what is incredibly hard to quantify
um because
um there's wide ranging effects I mean
even if you just were to count the
number of let's say operations that
didn't get done in the Health Service
you could probably quantify that but for
train strikes for example
um you can quantify how many trains
don't travel and tickets that weren't
bought but then there's all the people
who might have not gone to work
um and couldn't work that day and then
there's other people who traveled on
buses or taxis so there's an increase in
output there it's it's really hard to
quantify it but what we know is that to
some extent the strikes have held back
GDP growth a bit but um I don't think
they are the reason why the UK economy
for example over the last couple of
years has struggled relative to some
other economies in Europe and North
America they're a very tiny parts of the
overall story if if you ask me well one
more point about the March number I
wanted to ask you about is um if there
is a crumb of comfort in it it's the
fact that manufacturing expanded during
the month I mean we've had quite a
protracted period of weakness in
manufacturing what was going on there do
you think
I think there's some relief here from
um the uh contraction in uh lots of
Supply chains um from the pandemic and
that particularly hurt the auto car
production sector and those uh supply
shortages eased last year so I think
manufacturers have started to benefit
from that they're able to produce a bit
more simply because they can get their
parts there's also been a bit of a
synchronized upturn in activity and lots
of uh European uh and North American
countries and China as well actually so
the manufacturing sector is more exposed
to Global Trends and the UK's
manufacturing sector has benefited to
some degree from just other economies
around the world starting to perform a
bit better as well okay Paul got to
leave it there appreciate you joining me
today thank you my pleasure
there's some breaking news now and the
British businessman Dr Mike Lynch has
been extradited to the United States the
founder and former chief executive of
the software company autonomy landed in
San Francisco yesterday weeks after
losing a long-running legal battle he's
expected to stand trial over allegations
that he manipulated autonomous accounts
to inflate its value ahead of its sale
to Hewlett-Packard Dr Lynch has always
denied those allegations we're joining
me now is our city editor Mark blyman
who broke the story this morning Mark
this is going to be really really
controversial a lot of British business
people were right behind Mike Lynch
yeah that's right uh in Mike Lynch has
always argued that if he were to face uh
criminal charges over uh the sale of
autonomy to Hewlett-Packard then that
trial should take place in the UK after
all autonomy uh was a London listed
company uh based in the UK and uh was
audited in Britain as well but as you
said he's been fighting a long-running
uh legal battle to avoid extradition he
lost the final round of that challenge
in the high court last month so today's
news is really inevitable he arrived in
San Francisco yesterday uh lunchtime and
it immediately uh went to a bowel
hearing at a U.S District Court in
California where the uh the judge
ordered him to pay a 100 million dollar
bail bond to secure his uh release it's
not clear whether that has been paid or
whether Mr Lynch will pay it but it is
it is an incredibly controversial case
in because of its use of the extradition
treaty between the UK and the US a
number of leading British business
figures the likes of Brent hopeman for
example the founder of lastminute.com
argued in a letter earlier this year to
Rishi sunak that this was an
unreasonable use of the treaty between
the two governments and that it was
excessive and not appropriate of course
we'd now seen that Dr Lynch has been
extradited to the US where he will face
trial a criminal trial at a future date
so obviously very bad news for Dr Lynch
that he has lost his extradition battle
and he is now in custody in the U.S
all right Mark thanks for that
some other stories for you now and
shares of thg fell by as much as 20 this
morning after the online retailing
platform said it had ended talks with
the US private Equity Firm Apollo over a
possible takeover thdu it specializes in
lines such as health and beauty said
that some Apollo had indicated it was
prepared to pay for the business had
fallen shorter the valuation the board
put on the company it said the board had
therefore concluded there was no longer
any Merit in continuing to engage with
Apollo thg added that it was continuing
to see improvements in its profitability
and cash flow
the drugs giant GSK said this morning it
sold 804 million pounds worth of shares
in Haley and the consumer Healthcare
business it spun off last year it said
it continues to earn 10.3 percent of
helion who which owns Brands including
censored on toothpaste Central minerals
and vultural Pain Relief well GSK said
it and the drugs giant Pfizer which owns
a further 32 percent of halian had
agreed not to sell any more shares in
the company for the next 60 days shares
of halim which was demered from GSK in
July last year are actually up one and
three quarter percent this morning
and Elon Musk has said overnight he has
appointed a new chief executive for
Twitter in a tweet on the social media
platform Mr musk who bought Twitter for
44 billion dollars last year said she
will be starting in around six weeks Mr
musk did not disclose the identity of
Twitter's new chief executive but the
Wall Street Journal is reporting that
Linda yaccarino who's head of
advertising at the broadcaster NBC
Universal is in talks to take the job
NBC Universal has the same parent
company as Sky News
foreign
on Wall Street last night was followed
by similarly mixed trade overnight for
equities in the Asia Pacific region both
Hong Kong and Shanghai fell on concerns
over Chinese growth but the Nikka and
Tokyo hit its best level since November
2021 on some solid corporate earnings
updates well in Europe stocks are
heading into the weekend on a largely
upbeat note too here's the picture all
of the main indices in Continental
Europe in positive territory right now
talking points today include stronger
than expected earning update from
Richmond that's the owner of Brands such
as Cartier and Mont Blanc it Shares are
had some six and a half percent in
Zurich and that's given a lift to other
luxury goods flares you'll notice that
the Kakarot in France is up nearly one
percent that's quite heavily weighted
towards luxury goods stocks we're here
in London the ftse 100 is also in
positive territory up nearly half of one
percent right now in a broad-based rally
the leading Blue Chip Gainer currently
is the Lloyds of London in Shore a
Beasley group the shares up five and a
quarter percent following the trading
update earlier on this morning I mean
while the private equity firm 3i
continues to be wanted after its results
yesterday and is ahead by some two and a
half percent on the downside but as you
can see Vodafone is off by more than
three quarters of one percent there's
some adverse broker comment uh chipping
away at it there diagio which you can
see in the middle of the screen there
off by one and a half percent for
similar reasons outside the ftse the
ready meal and sandwich maker back of
all it Shares are up by some three and a
half percent there was a bit of chunky
director buying there in that stock
yesterday but ITV as you can see remains
under a bit of a cloud following
Thursday's training update it's
currently off another one and three
quarter percent on the foreign exchange
markets well it's been uh fairly uh
quite morning to be honest with you uh
despite those GDP figures Sterling ahead
by Tenth the one percent against the US
dollar it's ahead by a quarter of one
percent against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile off by just under a
six of one percent against the Greenback
as for the oil price well that is
currently on course for its fourth
consecutive weekly fall that's largely
down to the big reverse it suffered
yesterday but crude will currently set
you back
74.71 cents a barrel that's off a third
of one percent joining me this morning
is Sophie London she's lead Equity
Analyst at Hargreaves lands done Sophie
good to see you um let's start with thg
I mean a bit of a bit of a
disappointment this for long-suffering
shareholders that's certainly one way
one way to put it really really dramatic
moves this morning yeah they're down as
much as 13
um really they are in an incredibly
difficult position let's not forget
they've only been listed for a few years
and they're down well over 90 on that on
that price
um so really difficult times and I think
what we need to keep in mind is that the
path to better profits for them is very
unclear and what we've seen is there
were talks of a takeover with Apollo
that's Fallen apart and that's why the
shares are suffering so badly this
morning I mean Matt molding the founder
and CEO is a big big show holder himself
do you think he's calling the shots in
this in terms of how the board responds
element of that that going on you know
he's been very very vocal particularly
around the Takeover chatter in terms of
what he will and won't accept and that
certainly offered debate about whether
or not that's that's the right course
but I would say that there's there's
certainly an element of strong control
from his side yes looking more broadly
at the 100 today I mean as I mentioned
it is in positive territory and any firm
reasons for that right now it's not been
on a bad run lately it hasn't you know
really it's ending the week with a bit
of a spring in its step which is always
nice to see
um frankly what we're seeing is that the
market is incredibly happy to hear that
the economy is expanding you know we
were expecting contractions until very
recently you know that big revision that
we heard of yesterday so there's that
um also there's been a lot of talk about
the fact that our labor market is still
very tight now as much as that's a
problem for inflation when you pick that
apart what it tells you is that there's
a lot of money still pumping around the
economy because people have a lot more
security job security and when people
feel confident in that way their
spending in the economy so that's
helpful as well and the final point on
that is that obviously an expanding
economy in a healthier economy helps the
banks which we know the ftse is very
much weighted towards absolutely of
course two-thirds of earnings in the
footsie come from overseas as well and
uh clearly economies like the US and
parts of the Arizona are doing quite
well yes absolutely and there's been
some some movements in currency
obviously at the moment as well
um and yeah the overseas is very very
important for the ftse so as much as you
might be looking domestically it's the
domestic Market those overseas
performances are incredibly important
now what about the oil prices I
mentioned uh this is four weeks in a row
it's Fallen now there was a big sell-off
yesterday mainly on U.S gasoline
inventories but there's a bit of a tug
of war going on here I mean it's still
quite trading at quite a tight range
yeah very very tight range and really
this is quite a sharp reversal from um
from upswings we've seen more recently
and essentially what we're seeing is the
Biden Administration initially said they
were going to cut a lot of production
which caused a spike because of the
supply constraints but there has
actually been a bit of a higher
inventory levels than expected in the US
coupled with demand concerns
particularly in the biggest importer
which is China and so essentially at the
moment it appears that Global recession
refers are winning that that tug of war
which is why we're seeing that downwards
pressure on the price all right so if we
were out of time I'm afraid great to
have you in the studio this morning
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live The
Tick Tock takeover of Eurovision I'll be
speaking next to its general manager for
marketing and operations in UK and
Ireland stay tuned
[Music]
eight years ago I arrived here 2015 it
was an election in Eurovision and got
sucked in immediately into politics and
Eurovision and uh it was the first year
Australia was in and I was thinking
Australia and you know what's going on
here then I noticed over the years that
there's a few other countries that are
not European technically either and
they're Israel's in there as a Bajan and
things like that and I thought why
shouldn't we be in here you know we're a
Colonial Country we've got a lot of
links there's a lot of new zealanders
here a lot of business networks and
things like that so um we want to have
someone to support each year okay to
that end there's a video that's been
released
um let's have a look at it and then you
can tell me
version
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so we um we actually came up with
the idea we'd been talking about like
why isn't New Zealand and Eurovision
came up with the idea it just happened
to be at like a kiwi networking party
and I met uh the like cousin's best
friends dog groomers yeah yeah of uh of
Laura and the band there it's Laura and
Joseph and uh and it sort of all clicked
together just sort of felt like two
worlds colliding like right at the right
time we dropped them a line in typical
kiwi fashion they were just like yeah
yeah we're in in 48 hours they had a
demo of the song to us so we're the feet
on the ground here to sort of make it
happen they're still back in New Zealand
but they'll be touring here later this
year and hopefully we can sort of give
it another push yeah it's like there's a
you know a group of people that are
really really passionate about it and uh
part of the issue is obviously time
difference it's when it's kicking off
over here it's first thing in the
morning and we're going to try and make
a movement to make that the best
breakfast TV to watch in New Zealand and
try and grow that based
welcome back now calendar for Scopes
you'll notice that tomorrow evening is
the final of the Eurovision song contest
this year's event is being held in
Liverpool and for the second year in a
row the Chinese video platform Tick Tock
is the main sponsor as its official
entertainment partner well all over the
city of Liverpool you can see last
year's runner-up Sam Ryder fronting a
new tech talk campaign to encourage
other artists to launch their careers on
the video site we'll joining me now from
Liverpool is James Stafford he's text
talks general manager for marketing and
operations in the UK and Ireland uh
James welcome to you before we get on to
uh what you're doing with Eurovision
obviously tick tock's become quite a
controversial brand here in the UK
concerns over Online safety for children
more recently National Security I mean
what would you say to parents who are
nervous about their children using
tiktok
yeah firstly thanks for having me I'm
incredibly excited so uh you know we
work with all of our stakeholders
parents with governments with all of our
partners like uh Eurovision and BBC to
uh listen to their specific concerns
that they have around using the platform
from a safety or from a data point of
view and address them we're more than
happy to be transparent about the plans
that we have for protecting UK data
within uh Europe and we talk you know
very openly about all of the products
and features we have that parents can
use to keep themselves safer to keep
their children safe on the platform but
we are really proud of the joyful and
inclusive and entertaining experience
that we provide that we don't uh we
don't try from that I mean the
government is pushing through an online
safety Bill aimed at keeping children
safe and keeping big tech companies to
account are you supportive of that
endeavor
yeah we support any uh effort to um you
know to ensure that children and all
users of the internet can be safe and
protected when they use that so we're
working really collaboratively with the
government and we'll support
um uh any efforts
obviously the UK government has just
banned Tick Tock from its official
devices on security concerns have you
made any representations to the
government about that
yeah so we expressed that we were
disappointed with the decision but we uh
you know we understand that the UK
government uh has advised that use of
tech talk like other other you know
social devices on corporate devices
should be avoided and you know we
actively proactively engage uh with with
all of our stakeholders including
governments to understand what those
concerns are and share what our plans
are um you know in in the area of Online
safety and in the area of data security
to make sure that we can give confidence
to all of our partners that we are a
responsible partner in this area so are
you a talks ongoing with the UK
government then do you think there's any
chance of getting them to reverse this
decision
I won't speculate on on the decision of
the government but we're definitely
engaged with with um you know all of our
stakeholders including the UK government
on addressing what their concerns are
how much data from Tick Tock uses is
made available to the Chinese government
so no data um from from Tick Tock users
Tick Tock is is not a Chinese company
tick to talk it's a global company
headquartered uh in Los Angeles and
Singapore
user data from the UK uh is is currently
stored in the US and Singapore and very
soon will be stored uh in in Europe if
the Chinese government requested
um a use of data we would we would
reject that it's not
um you know Sovereign countries like the
UK and not compelled to you know break
their own data security rules on the
request of any government including
China
well let's talk about what you're doing
with with Eurovision obviously you're
broadcasting a lot of the concerts
yourself do you see yourself as being in
competition here with the BBC
necessarily
no absolutely I mean we are a partner of
the BBC and we have been really open
about the fact that we would be really
successful as a platform if the BBC is
incredibly successful at you know making
sure that as many people as possible
tune in on on Saturday night to watch
the competition live so we are
proactively partnering with them to make
sure that we're capturing as much
attention and audience on Tech talk and
and at eight o'clock switching them all
over to watch uh live you know we're a
partner of broadcasters we're incredibly
uh proud to work with them
we've learned overnight that the
European broadcasting Union has turned
down a request from president zielinski
to address the event would you have
liked to have seen him being able to
speak
uh I mean I won't I won't uh comment on
behalf of the the Ebu or president
sulevsky uh you know we respect their
decisions I think
um you know they they know absolutely
what is right for Eurovision and the uh
you know the spirit of the contest
now you're obviously as well as
partnering Eurovision you're also
working with visit Liverpool to try and
boost tourism to to the city there what
sort of initiatives have you got
underway
yeah from the very start um of this
project we were so excited by the uh you
know the the joy of Eurovision but
importantly the opportunity that this
can bring to the host City uh and to the
businesses that depend on on that you
know Liverpool is highly dependent on
tourism especially music tourism
um has an amazing live uh venues and
cultural institutions they were
decimated by covert so at the heart of
our partnership has been you know
Revival Economic Opportunity and
cultural Revival so we are you can see
behind me you can see uh We've erected
some busking spots for local artists to
perform uh you know not just in front of
the visiting crowds but to the 150
million Europeans who use Tech talk uh
we partnered with small businesses about
200 businesses and cultural institutions
are now on board and we're helping them
to promote themselves across uh Europe
you'll see Billboards including one uh
just over there showcasing some of the
most important Tick-Tock businesses on
the platform and we've got about 50 of
the biggest tick tock creators from
across Europe here Liverpool visiting
reviewing all of those places visiting
the institutions and you know really
compelling their audiences back home to
come and visit Liverpool so we hope that
will leave a really successful lasting
Legacy for Eurovision on The Economic
Opportunity and cultural impact of
Liverpool
well it looks like you brought the
sunshine with you James anyway looks a
lot brighter when you are than it is
here in London this morning so enjoy the
event thanks for joining me
thank you it's been a pleasure
still to come here on Ian King live
we're going to be speaking to the
founder and chief executive of the
athleisure brand gymshark about its
plans for the future don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back at the athleisure brand Jim
Shaw has not had many setbacks since it
was founded 11 years ago by the
entrepreneur Ben Francis the business
was valued at more than one billion
pounds when in 2020 the U.S private
Equity Firm General Atlantic acquired a
21 stake so eyebrows were raised when
the company recently reported a 40
decline in full year pre-tax profits to
27.8 million pounds for joining me now
is Jim shocks founder and chief
executive Ben Francis been great to see
you this morning I don't want to get too
bogged down in the numbers but I'm in
the decline in profits that you
announced recently that was all largely
down to higher costs because you're
investing so much
yeah I mean we were affected like uh
most other companies with increased
material cost freight cost Logistics
costs and all of these things but
um we also are aware of the fact that we
want to build a truly iconic uh Global
brand so we also didn't want to slow
down investments from a brand point of
view during that period as well
you haven't taken a dividend for two
years I mean it feels like you're
investing most of your profits right now
back into the business
yes absolutely like I said we're our
real ambition and my my personal
ambition is I'd love to build a like I
said a British brand but a globally
iconic brand and ultimately a brand that
lasts longer than I do so you can't
invest in your brand just when times are
good you have to invest in the bright
and consistently over a prolonged period
of time and that's what we're really
focusing on doing now now in October
last year you you opened your first
store in London's West End is that
traded in line with your expectations
it's actually it's been ahead it's
genuinely been ahead pretty much every
single day and year to day it's it's a
it's a Well way ahead so we're really
really pleased and and being honest that
was that was tough for us because we've
only ever sold sort of single orders
online so so to go into an offline
strategy was operationally difficult for
us but I'm really really proud of what
that store has done and not only has it
been really successful from a commercial
perspective but I think we've also shown
the retail world what can be achieved
with the store because it's quite an
incredible experience as well has it
wetted your appetite to open more
Outlets then
uh I think it's something that we're
looking at now I think again if we zoom
out and look at building out a 100 Year
brand I genuinely think a 100 Year brand
needs multiple touch points we need
touch points that are online that are
offline and I think in the future is
definitely definitely something that we
should be looking at obviously having
been previously online you had a really
good insight into your consumers and the
sort of uh things that they're
interested in and the demographics and
so on is that harder in an offline
environment
uh yes and no because I think in an
offline environment you'll get less of
the large quantities of hard data but
then you can have some really really
important and interesting conversations
with customers and even I try and get
into the store at least once or twice a
month and just chatting to people about
what they like what they don't like
improvements in the products I think
those things can sometimes be
underestimated as to just how important
they are
you mentioned earlier on the freight
costs and other supply chain issues are
you starting to see those abating now
yes yes we are and I think the going
back to the numbers Ian the the numbers
were accounts that were ended uh July
last year so in the last particularly
the last few months we've seen costs
sort of start to ease and get better and
the business is continuing to grow so
we're really optimistic about the next
sort of year moving forward
and how do you assess the strength of
consumer confidence right now I mean
obviously we've had news this morning
that UK GDP unexpectedly contracted in
March a lot of that is being put down to
lower disposable incomes what are you
seeing right now
yeah I mean we're very very uh spread
globally I mean I think something like
60 70 of our revenue is outside of the
UK half of that's in North America uh
specifically in the UK we've actually
seen really really good performance the
last couple of months and it's been a
little bit surprising if I'm honest
given the
um the Outlook and the the I guess the
noises coming from the media and like
you say the interest rise that's just
happened but
um so recently we've seen really really
strong UK performance and we do think
that that's down to the store and the
brand and just having a really strong
and clear proposition in the market
you mentioned there the importance of of
North America to you in particular is is
that in right now your priority in terms
of growing the business and growing the
brand
uh yeah I mean it's I mean we've got a
few priorities at the moment but yeah
the US is certainly one of those it's
the biggest active wearing Fitness
Market in the world uh we're still very
small in the United States we've got a
growing presence so yeah it's a big
priority and we see it as a big big
opportunity moving forward
all right Ben we've got to leave it
there I'm afraid hope to see you again
in future it's been great talking to you
today
thank you I appreciate it
I think we might have a bit of breaking
news to bring you now uh we've just
heard that the former Pakistani prime
minister Imran Khan has arrived at the
court in Islamabad you can see the
pictures on your screen there he was
under heavy security cover as his
supporters clashed with police elsewhere
in the city recall of course Imran Khan
was arrested earlier in the week and
that was subsequently overturned as
being unlawful by the courts in
Islamabad more on that throughout the
morning as we get it here on Sky News
now during a cost of living crisis some
consumers may be tempted to squeeze
every last available drop from their
household appliances rather than shell
out to replace them when they break well
that in theory should be good news for
domestic in general the UK's leading
provider of Appliance care for the
company which employs a network of 9 000
Engineers has other challenges of its
own including supporting the push for
Energy Efficiency well joining me now is
the chief executive of domestic in
general Matthew Crum Matthew good to see
you good morning this morning I mean is
that a fair pointer oh call outs
increasing as people try and keep their
appliances going for longer well
certainly the cost of living crisis has
meant a lot of people have deferred new
Appliance purchases certainly in the
last year or so and actually repairing
appliances and making them last longer
has been a key consideration for many
people certainly that's what we've seen
we a lot of much of our business the
vast majority is on a subscription basis
so we have nearly 5 million customers in
the UK
uh they pay monthly they're able to
cancel at any time on that plan yet
we've maintained our retention level of
those customers at 85 percent actually
and the reason we believe that is
because they customers value actually
being able to call up and have somebody
out repair the appliance most people
like repairing their appliances and
keeping their own appliances they like
their their own washing machines their
dishwashers they even call them names
sometimes would you believe it but
actually they like keeping that so
having tried to repair my washing
machine I think they're mental for
thinking what about costs what are you
seeing there on the cost of the actual
plan itself yes certainly yeah yeah so
we we're very thoughtful about that and
uh so we ran some proprietary research
uh uh in the last in the last few months
looking at how consumers rate this
particular subscription which is an
insurance product
and actually it's at the bottom of the
pile uh relative to all the other
subscriptions for things that people
would cancel right and the reason that
it is is because actually when you take
those nearly five million customers the
demographic of those family matches
almost identically the demographic UK so
you have people on low incomes with our
policies new people at high incomes and
that people are low income buy it for
protection because they don't want to
have to spend 500 pounds or 400 pounds
on a new Appliance and the people at the
high end actually buy it for convenience
now so but actually they see value in
that and that's why we've maintained
retention now obviously you know we uh
we adjust pricing as we go through
through the year but we do that very
very cautiously and obviously the fact
we've been able to maintain retention
throughout the years at this level is an
indication of the of the value what's
the typical cost of a policy well it can
just be a few pounds on a starting uh
for us for a starter machine and it
depends very much of course the type of
machine you know at the high end you've
got uh some machines which can cost
thousands of pounds at the low end uh a
bit less and uh it's this is not like
ensuring a person on a car you don't
drive a washing machine and so you you
know they're very much quite predictable
uh in how they break down and what they
do so it's very cheap at the beginning a
few pounds to to to to protect that but
as you go through the lifetime of a
machine let's say across the lifetime an
average of 10 years we might repair a
machine three times that's interesting
what about uh Parts we've been talking a
lot about supply chain shortages lately
has that been an issue over the last 12
to 15 months it was certainly an issue
at the sort of very peak of the supply
chain crisis and it's very much trying
to get the right parts at the right time
um if you imagine our five million
customers we have everything from
washing machines to Tumble dryers to TVs
and a network of 99 years to support
that so the the possible combinations
and all of that and the right spare
parts at the right time is quite
mind-blowing so what we have been doing
is uh bringing data and using machines
to help us better predict and better
organize ourselves and our engineer
Partners to try and get to the right
place at the right time I thought
something for AI that now what about
Energy Efficiency is that something that
consumers are necessarily fixated on
during a cost of living crisis I I think
um for us at least what we see is a is a
is a real focus on extending the life of
the appliance they and we we don't we
see certainly on new Appliance purchases
more focus on Energy Efficiency we hear
consumers we do call listening I do call
listing and we hear consumers talk about
how Energy Efficiency is this machine
but that tends to be for new appliances
for existing ones it's more about
extending that life out the longer it
lasts clearly the better it is because
you're not then shipping a new one
Halfway Around the World taking the old
one away and that's really why our
business has been so sustainable really
over time and that's why we think it's a
sustainable business both economically
and environmentally all right Matthew
loads are wanting to ask you but I'm
afraid nice to see we haven't had you on
the program for a while so yeah thanks
very much
[Music]
time have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with the bank
of England's interest rate rise
yesterday inside the paper's economics
editor Chris Giles writes that the
bank's Governor Andrew Bailey faced
tough questionnaire on The credibility
of the bank's forecasting the ft is
currently leading its Digital Editions
meanwhile with a very interesting story
that PWC is racing to contain the global
Fallout of an Australian leak Scandal on
its business after it emerged that the
company used government tax plans to
advise its Tech lines the times leads
its business pages with a bank of
England rate rice but it also reports
that revolutes Chief Financial Officer
and UK banking Chief are leaving and
what it says is the latest in a series
of senior departures from the company
Daily Telegraph also leads with the bank
of England and homes in on its warning
that Britain faces elevated levels of
inflation now for nearly two years
Telegraph also reports on a meeting
between supermarket Jason John Glenn the
chief secretary to the treasury in which
they told him government regulations
were pushing up their costs and
contributing to a surge in food prices
well joining me now several on a Friday
morning is the financial markets
commentator and evening standard
Economist Neil Collins Neil good to see
you this morning one story that caught
your eye is uh shell the Church of
England pension fund uh is voting
against the reappointment of the CEO
yes I they don't think that shell is
going green quickly enough and they are
protesting I mean they don't have many
shares they used to have quite a few but
they've sold them down so they're one
million pound total investment is really
not going to move the dial at Shell but
I suspect others will follow them so
there is a bit of a problem here but um
my point is that it's all very well to
highlight the problems of trying to turn
an oil company into a a business of uh
as I described as sunbeams and windmills
um but it's a very difficult thing to do
and it's extremely difficult to do it
while making money and the uh the remix
for the people at the top of shell of
course is not to do uh to save the world
it's to make a decent return on the vast
Capital that they employ and the the
people who are protesting don't really
seem to grasp this uh put it this way if
shell decided it was not going to do any
more oil drilling then I suspect that
the executives would be on the end of a
lawsuit from from the U.S investors
because the valuation put on Exxon which
has got a much more robust approach to
the uh to the green lobby is about 50
percent higher than shell so if shell is
on the same rating as Exxon it would be
worth 80 billion pounds more than it is
today so you know that is the the num
the Stark numbers if you like
um the other point that I think I've
made in my column is that the amount of
so-called Damage Done by the Western oil
companies is Tiny compares the amount of
damage done by other doubtful operators
in strange parts of the world
and the example I quote is in
Turkmenistan where the extraction of
methane which is a much more potent
greenhouse gas than CO2 is essentially
so inefficient that it contributes more
to uh to the output of
CO2 equivalent than the entire United
Kingdom that's just from their gas
fields from gas which is wasted so I you
know I do think the protesters although
I'm sure they're well-meaning really
should get a sense of proportion and I
suspect they're attacking shell because
they can
rather than because they think it's
really going to make any difference yes
extraordinary uh statistic that from
Turkmenistan you've just quoted that
before I let you go Neil what's your
reaction to Mike Lynch's extradition I
mean it's something that you and I have
both written about over the years
yeah well uh
um tactic to Sky News for for
revealing the scoop that he was being
extradited he's now gone on a hundred
million dollar bail
um his defense seems to me to be
basically saying well we're a British
company I'm British and it therefore
should be held here uh and I think that
in terms of the the substance of the
complaints that Hewlett-Packard have
against him the the judges on more than
one occasion have said that they are
very substantial the the allegations of
Fraud and really the the place to have
them uh answered is in the courts uh the
thing that always puzzled me about
autonomy his company was that it was
valued very highly but there was always
a minority of analysts who said this
thing shouldn't fly they didn't actually
say fraud but they said we can't make
the numbers work we think they're
confusing hardware sales and soft Square
sales and we don't like it at all so
despite that Hewlett-Packard went ahead
and paid 11 billion dollars it seems to
me that their complete failure to do due
diligence is one of the main reasons why
there was such a mess and they paid a
vast amount they had to write off 8
billion of it when they realized what
the uh true position was so you know
it's all very well them having a go uh
at Mike Lynch and saying you know we
want to see him in court uh it does
strike me to some extent as being sort
of Revenge and spite yeah Caveat Emptor
Neil good to see you this morning thank
you
pleasure
still to come here on Ian King live how
artificial intelligence could impact
customer service and help those most
vulnerable don't go away
thank you
[Music]
eight years ago I arrived here 2015 it
was an election in Eurovision and got
sucked in immediately into politics and
Eurovision and uh it was the first year
Australia was in and I was thinking
Australia and you know what's going on
here then I noticed over the years that
there's a few other countries that are
not European technically either in there
Israel's in there as a Bajan and things
like that and I thought why shouldn't we
be in here you know we're a Colonial
Country we've got a lot of links there's
a lot of new zealanders here a lot of
business networks and things like that
so um we want to have someone to support
each year okay to that end there's a
video that's been released
um let's have a look at it and then you
can tell me
[Music]
let us enter Euro version
yeah so we um we actually came up with
the idea we'd been talking about like
why isn't New Zealand and Eurovision
came up with the idea it just happened
to be at like a kiwi networking party
and I met uh the like cousin's best
friends dog groomer yeah yeah of uh of
Laura and the band there it's Laura and
Joseph and uh and it's sort of all
clicked together just sort of felt like
two worlds colliding like right at the
right time we dropped them a line in
typical kiwi fashion they were just like
yeah yeah we're in in 48 hours they had
a demo of the song to us so we're the
feet on the ground here to sort of make
it happen they're still back in New
Zealand but they'll be touring here
later this year and hopefully we can
sort of give it another push yeah it's
like there's a you know a group of
people that are really really really
passionate about it and uh part of the
issue is obviously time difference so
when it's kicking off over here it's
first thing in the morning and we're
going to try and make a movement to make
that the best breakfast TV to watch in
New Zealand and try and grow that based
foreign
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now so we've been reporting
on this program during the last couple
of weeks businesses are working hard to
integrate generative AI like chat GPT
into their operations one field in which
the technology has seen as offering
particular Advantage is in improving
customer service an example could be in
helping utility companies set up
dedicated phone lines for vulnerable
customers something energy companies
were this week ordered to do by the
regulator off gem well joining me now
live from New York is Barack Alam he's
the chief executive of nice the 12
billion dollar Global Enterprise
software provider Barrack good to see
you this morning thank you for joining
me it's such an unsociable hour
um how can AI help in a situation like
this
thank you very much for having me and
good morning uh from uh from New York uh
AI is a true game changer for the
customer service uh space it actually
tackles three very long-standing
challenges that enterprises are facing
when it comes to customer service the
first one is the lack of skilled labor
the ability to take decision at a very
high pace and velocity and of course
Mass personalization at scale something
that we as consumers all want when it
comes to getting service from our
providers
Barack how difficult is it for for
businesses to gen to integrate
generative AI into their custom support
systems
so it's actually not that easy I know
that we have all already somewhat
experience different generative AI
Technologies and you know it does
humanize the conversation for us as uh
human beings but when it comes to
Enterprises they have different goals
they have the ability or the need to
protect the brand and provide certain
type of services to their consumers and
of course they have different business
goals so just taking generative AI is is
to the operation is distant to to
failure and just doesn't work and that's
what I hear from the thousands of
customers that that we have what you
need to do and this is what we provide
as a company with thousands of customers
around the globe you actually need to
take the AI technology Infuse it with a
lot of information in historical data
that is domain specific from different
tens of billions of past interactions
with consumers in order to make it work
in this environment and you need to have
it highly specialized for the the
customer service space in order a for
consumers to enjoy it in the right way
and B for Brands to actually trust the
technology and make sure it works as one
of their employees if you would like and
not just as someone that is not familiar
with the brand or with the different
business goals that they have
now Barak you have customers over a
number of different industry areas the
likes of American Airlines Morgan
Stanley Radisson hotels are you seeing
much difference in the speed at which
various sectors are integrating AI into
what they do
so I I would say I I think I talk with
customers on a regular basis and it's
kind of divided into two camps once it
says you know I'm not gonna deploy it in
my environment it's too dangerous for us
and the others that are excited towards
you know deploying AI but they just want
to do it in a safe and trusted ways that
their consumers can can do and and we
see it across as you said we operate
across almost all verticals with
thousands of customers around the uh the
globe but since they have our platform
uh which we call cx1 it allows them to
you know experience Ai and editing it in
a safety way but I can't say that I see
many many differences between verticals
everyone understand today that customer
service is the way for Brands to
differentiate from one another it's a
true competitive differentiation so the
excitement is there it's just about
making sure it is deployed deployed
correctly and doesn't fire back
Barack we have to leave it there I'm
afraid thank you again for joining me at
such an early uh time of the day and
also because you had your results out
yesterday which must have been very uh
tiring as well so thank you thank you
very much for having me
that's it from me I'm back on Monday at
10 o'clock Coke very much to see you
then in the meantime do stay tuned
coming up next it's Sam Washington with
all the latest on that court appearance
from Pakistan for the former prime
minister Imran Khan thanks very much for
joining me today have a good weekend
cheerio
[Music]